are you following bad YouTube advice
that is hurting your channel posting
more videos gets you more views it's
false you need to Niche down on YouTube
to succeed true or false I'm gonna go
true 99 of people who say they're being
Shadow banned are just putting out
crappy content and they're trying to
blame somebody else and it's a victim
perspective and you're gonna lose with
that mentality
you know there's a lot of outdated
strategies out there that are being
perpetuated by the gurus and so in this
episode of the think media podcast we're
going to be talking about what's true
and what's false when it comes to
YouTube tips and strategies and I'm
pumped because we got Nolan and Omar on
the podcast Nolan how's it going so good
I'm happy to be here I just want to jump
right into the first one because we got
some great uh I'm gonna read a statement
and this is how it's going to work Omar
you're going to say true or false uh
I'll jump in there Sean true or false
and we're going to discuss this that I
think the beauty of this though is we
might disagree on some of these and so
I'm excited for just the perspectives of
uh everybody here so the first one is
posting more videos gets you more views
Omar I'm curious your perspective true
or false what do you think the first
thing that comes to mind is true because
how do you even know what's getting
views unless you experiment and upload
videos 100 and one of the things that I
actually thought about was that time
when we came onto the think media
channel and we went this was uh 2020 I
think March Cove it's happening and we
started going from what was it two a
week to five a week do you remember what
it was Sean was it was about two a week
yep and we go more than double uploads
and I just remember our like our view
Camp if you go back and we'll do a
little screen yeah we'll do a little
screen thinking like Arrow like pointing
here you'll see it just like almost like
double views and so there is a there is
a truth to it there's also the other
side that I would argue that
in a certain way it could be false
because some people when they do that
they don't have a team around them and
so you have these solo creators who try
to pump up pump out more content and
they're making worse videos can you
speak to that too Sean because I know
there's people in our community who do
that and sometimes the right answer is
actually post less though posting more
can get you more views it's like an
oxymoron yeah the mistake of a lot of
small YouTube creators is they feel like
a lot of uploads is a badge of honor but
the problem is if you keep uploading
piles of poop all you have is just more
piles of poop and so there's a quality
factor to it you don't want to be overly
judgmental of the fact that like it is
of course the content value not the
production value but sometimes people
they're just there's not a strategy the
titles aren't right the the content's
not super valuable so if you can
maintain quality while increasing
quantity than if you double your uploads
you'll probably double your views that's
so good uh the next one is interesting
because I hear both of this so much but
here's the statement and I want to know
true or false Sean search content is
outdated people YouTubers should only
focus on browse and suggest that this is
kind of a a new trend especially like Mr
Beast Iraq these guys are making Ultra
viral videos and so people look to these
guys and they're like dude like I should
be doing what they're doing search
content like no one's searching for
these videos that Mr Beast is making and
so I get where they're coming from but
do you think this is actually true or
false I think it's false I think um I
understand where people are coming from
because what happens is people mix
YouTube topics and strategies I mean
there's entertainment and there's
education and we speak to so many
Educators that are tapping into the
power of search based content and
there's massive opportunity there it's
100 still a search engine a lot of
critics also come pair the education
channels to the entertainment channels
and they go oh if they don't get a
million views they're not valuable and
we work with so many business owners and
stuff that have one five 10 million
dollar a year a month businesses with
small traffic it's really kind of about
the business model it's about the
strategy but I even heard I mean there's
some notable social media voices Gary
vaynerchuk was talking about how YouTube
shorts from a search standpoint is a
huge opportunity if you were doing like
a Niche Wine show our friends at vid IQ
were building a video editing PC or a
gaming PC and every piece they were
searching for the gaming PC was a ranked
short based on search because if you can
answer the question in less than 60
seconds it may not be going viral but
it's going to get that slow and steady
wins type of traffic and so it's not
really either or it's and both in this
case I love that you brought up YouTube
shorts ranking because I was I was
trying to cook some something and I
noticed for the first time at the top of
my search was the shorts shelf and it
was exactly what I was looking for and
it makes sense too because I don't
really want to watch like a three minute
long video on how to grill chicken on my
on my uh on my charcoal grill and so I
watched the short end it makes sense
from a viewer standpoint and it's
something to consider and what I found
was interesting is we in 2022 think
media YouTube search was 47.6 of our
total views and so we have
dude half of our audiences coming
through search and I know you produce a
lot of search content can you real
quickly before we get to the next one
talk about like kind of some people get
discouraged because they post a search
video and it's like 10 out of 10. I
don't get discouraged yeah so talk to me
about that no I I think one of the most
underrated stats that people aren't
encouraging is real-time View when you
go into your YouTube Studio on the right
side of your screen you're going to see
the amount of views you're getting in
every 48 hour period that is such a
powerful stat and we average around 350
000 views and we're meeting that many
people every 48 Hours like meeting or
we're meeting again and I love that I
don't I don't want I don't like the game
and it is there's a preference to it
just based off of the way my brain works
and my personality I don't like the game
where my last upload well you know like
my next upload is has to be my best
upload and that's just that's not I
don't know the compound interest on that
emotional toil I'm not trying to go into
but I'll upload a video I know it won't
perform well but we'll look back in a
year from now and be like sick 150k yeah
yeah that's a good point because even Mr
Beast has said like he feels the
pressure that he's always trying to
one-up himself right whereas if you're
also playing kind of in the Practical
search game you're not really trying to
one-up yourself you're just consistently
pulling out valuable content that's sort
of a slow and steady wins and not
playing The Sensational game and we I
mean I mean make your thumbnails better
make your titles better let's get that
click-through rate but there's so much
practical opportunity on YouTube and
sometimes there's a lot of wisdom in
that Simplicity this next one's
controversial a lot of people are gonna
be triggered by this one in the comments
um we're gonna talk about YouTube tags
here's the statement true or false using
tags gets you more views on YouTube
what do you say Sean it's false
using tags will not get you more views
in isolation if you also referencing the
pile of poop we were discussing earlier
if you tag a pile of poop well it's
still a pile of poop and so tags should
be
affirmation that you made a good video
and you did great research and
what's funny is me saying that tags
actually getting you views is false I
still see the value in tags because if
you do your research properly you're
looking for a long tail keyword video
topics and you also are adding the right
tags it's metadata as well as
description and title and you use a tool
like good IQ it tells you like this
video is ranking for these different
tags it's not that the tags influence
the video in any way it's simply that
your process is verified and aligned by
the tags you finally added the video so
let me ask you this though uh on tags
because people who maybe are just
getting started on YouTube or doing it
for a while haven't found success they
hear that you know a lot of people are
saying just like tags are worthless
and what you're saying is
adding tags isn't going to help you get
views there's way more important things
you need to do but should the person
who's starting out they're making
content should they leave the tags blank
or can it actually because you're
talking about metadata does it actually
help them rank in search is it one of
those kind of factors like maybe it
doesn't what are your thoughts on that
should they add in tags I would say that
you should do everything YouTube gives
you the opportunity to do and you should
use a tool like vid IQ because if you
use it properly you can add tags in
about 30 seconds or less and it's really
quick and easy but in terms of influence
your title is going to carry a lot more
weight than tags and if something search
based the words used used in the title
that still appeal to humans but also are
very clickable that would be the
greatest weight then your description
would carry more weight than tags
because that's a little blog post there
may be some influence metadata wise
there what you say in your video itself
and the caption file even if you don't
do the caption file and the content
content itself would be the next thing
to optimize so tags is just at the
bottom of the list and I think it's like
about a one percent influence this is
from the mouth of YouTube they said that
tags also help with spelling errors that
one of the things that you can add in
your tags is alternative versions of of
maybe the topic that you're going after
to kind of flush out those details and
so yeah I think they're worth doing and
I think that I would recommend a new
Creator or small Channel understand the
reasoning behind using tags because when
you develop that discipline you're going
to be a better content creator over
overall you're going to be thinking
about how do I structure my video come
up with a great topic title it well
can you know build a good script for it
or a good outline for it and just align
all of those details that's what we talk
about in our video ranking Academy
program is literally just understanding
like blank page to published video and
it's a piece of the pie it's just such a
small piece and where I think people go
into air is they
they major on the miners and sometimes
they minor on the majors they spend more
time thinking about video optimization
in terms of metadata as opposed to
really investing a ton of energy and
making the best video possible I think
part I think part of making the best
video possible is finding the right
videos to make which is the perfect
segue to tell people to go watch our
think master class because honestly in
if you go to thinkmastercross.com it's a
free training and you share like much
more practical advice that is important
and matters right now so if you are
using tags you're on YouTube You're Just
you haven't been able to figure it out
or you're looking to scale just the
content you already have I definitely
recommend go to thinkmasterclass.com
check it out it's a really cool training
that we offer for free over there and I
think there's just a ton of value that
um where you just go deeper on some of
those things that really matter for
YouTube and so definitely check that out
link is in the description yeah and just
another two cents on the tag thing I do
like it as another point of measuring
success like if we make a video around
something that we're trying to ride the
influence of that whether it's a person
or a product or a software that like we
can see how it's performing at a glance
you know based off of the various
keywords that we use inside of the tags
so I like it as a point of measuring we
a success uploaded a video the other day
and it ranks number one two three seven
five on various different things around
that camera so it just gives us good
peace to know that like the video is
working you know yeah I love that what's
really cool too about the YouTube studio
now is you can go in there and if you
actually go into your analytics and you
go over to your reach and you're looking
at just where are these views coming
from YouTube will show you uh not just
how much percent of the video is from
search but it will show you the Search
terms which I think is really cool so
YouTube's evolving it's um search isn't
dead tags are useful and uh it's really
cool but I have the next one for you
Omar which I'm curious to hear your
thoughts though I feel like I already
know your answer on this one but the
thing is a lot of people don't believe
this okay so here's the statement
YouTube is over saturated what what do
you say true or false I think it's false
um because and the thing I like to say
is if you're not on YouTube then it's
not oversaturated that's the the beauty
of YouTube is the uniqueness of the
Creator the experiences that a creator
has and that's why we're seeing new
creators come up on the come up and
quick have grow growth or grow quickly
and so I I like to say YouTube needs you
you know YouTube needs your uniqueness
and
as long as you're not uploading then
it's not crowded yeah I totally agree I
just started a brand new YouTube channel
did not promote it did not do any ads or
shout it out or tell people to go follow
it uh just started it I let YouTube do
its thing I I just followed basically
our perfect video recipe just the stuff
that we teach and um and I think
masterclass.com
uh and you know it blew up I mean in a
sense that like one of the videos got a
million views a couple hundred thousand
views it's I got monetized within a
month this is a brand new channel though
so I I you know it's it's just cool to
see that and I have a another friend who
he did the the same thing we're in this
like we call it a Creator Mastermind but
we just meet once a week and we talk
about YouTube and he started a brand new
gaming channel to talk about over what
people think is oversaturated started a
brand new gaming channel and his first
video within a couple weeks hits a
million views dudes monetized making
money he just dropped another video it's
doing well and it's it's encouraging to
people who are sitting on the sideline
still because
get in the game there is so much room
and just I think you even know some of
the statistics about just how many
people are still on YouTube there's room
yeah and I love that about YouTube yeah
I mean I think that saturation is a myth
when it comes to YouTube and I think
with 2.6 billion monthly active users
the consumption is so high and the
desire for great content it's really a
supply and demand and there's just
endless demand which means there's an
opportunity for creators to start and
contribute the supply but you know I'm
empathetic I think when people hear
those stories they just think yeah but
I'm I'm stuck or I just I'm not growing
it feels oversaturated and admittedly
there is a massive skill set to build
like we I kind of feel like maybe here
at think media after you know being
pulled out of the Matrix and then like
pulled into the dojo to like learn how
to fight from Morpheus and then
eventually we finally like wake up up
and we have kind of a revelation we're
like oh and now we can like see the
Matrix like and so we're dodging bullets
and it's bullet time and there's you
know and like all of a sudden and that's
you you started a brand new channel but
you're Nolan molt after years of testing
and experimenting and some failures and
training at think media and building out
your own stuff and and trying a bunch of
things Omar has put out some videos
reviews is video game tape just like
Kobe would always do after he won a game
or lost a game he would review the game
tape and think about how he could get
better on the next upload so if you have
the right skills if you can kind of
identify Trends psychology gaps in the
market no there's unlimited opportunity
on YouTube but if you're just doing the
same thing everybody else is doing if
you're just kind of playing by
yesterday's rules if you're unwilling to
learn if you're unwilling to grow if
you're unwilling to adapt and pivot then
it can feel very saturated I think the
one other thing to consider though
is YouTube can actually never be
saturated because every single day new
things happen
and a lot of creators are lazy even a
lot of successful creators they get
comfortable and they get complacent
so there's always new things to talk
about there's new products to review
there's new news events happening
there's new movies coming out there's
new TV shows coming out you know the
Lord of the Rings rings of power
was purchased the IP by Amazon they make
a new show Lord of the Rings is a big
brand but had not had didn't have
anything major happening the movies were
done The Hobbit movies were done and
then all of a sudden boom there's a
whole revitalization of people
interested in it thinking about the the
lore the books the board games the cards
the show and so 10 20 30 50 Lord of the
Rings channels can spawn off of things
happening in culture and new things will
always be happening in culture so if
you're following culture and Trends and
connecting that to your passion then
again there's something that's going to
happen in the next month that we don't
even know is going to happen right now
how many people have made videos about
chat GPT all I see now is actually
videos about like AI chat jpt but it's
actually a whole new opportunity and a
whole new set of videos to make about
how to do it what to do the cool things
gimmicks how to start side hustles how
to use it for YouTube how to use it for
business how to use it for Fitness how
to use it so there's new things
happening and because there's always new
things happening the new can never be
saturated because it just started today
and tomorrow isn't even here yet so if
you position yourself in your Nimble
then saturation is a myth the days bring
new distinctions
very good there we go
um so I feel like this is a good next
one to go into it
um you need to Niche down as a beginner
on YouTube to succeed
true or false I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
true
um I think you're you only help YouTube
by YouTube knowing what your channel is
about and
and by Niche I think I think that's
where like the the gray area is because
you can your Niche could be living in
New York and you can go to coffee shops
and go to restaurants and Vlog and that
could be your Niche
um so you don't have to like minimize
what your idea of a niche is but YouTube
essentially should know what your
channel is about and you help them by
posting consistent videos around a
specific
or gray Niche I guess you could say yeah
I think it's I think it's true
and false and in between so as far as
narrowing down my answer and Clarity
goes so but I mean I think that
there's examples of different creators
that sometimes they do start and they
experiment because they're so small yeah
you could post you know 50 videos none
of them break out and you're trying
different things and then one breaks out
but then what you do is you begin to
focus over time like your channel begins
to take on a life of its own and you
follow the clues of success you follow
the bread crumbs of the videos that are
performing well but I think if you
continue to post random content over
time then you'll never actually build a
significant brand but if you're just
starting experimenting I think could be
okay my favorite word this year more
than Niche is simply the word Focus like
what's the focus of the channel because
what for some people when they think
Niche down they're like it can't even be
a beauty Channel it has to only be Nails
it can't even just be Nails it has to be
nail art that has a cosplay angle and is
only World of Warcraft Nails because I
really want to stand out and be a
specific Niche you're like dude that's
too specific that's like that that's not
that so what's the focus though like
what is the focus of your YouTube
channel focus and I think that focus is
power the last thing is sort of like
what are you building so again you might
be experimenting at the start trying
different things but I think about like
going to a restaurant like when you want
to go to a restaurant you actually set
out with a specific intent in Focus
you're like I want to go get sushi
tonight so if you take your partner you
go get sushi and you're that's what you
expect that's what they become known for
and if you want to go somewhere else you
go somewhere else so on YouTube it's
like do you want to watch Comedy or do
you want to learn something or do you
want but imagine if you sat down at
Sushi been going there for eight weeks
and the server comes over to you and
just you know you put in your order but
then he decides to bring out chips salsa
a burrito like you might love Mexican
food as well but you're like what's
happening here like that's that's not
what I'm here for like what this is not
the focus of your they're like I just
feel like doing something different I
just feel like being creative there's
too many creators that actually do that
though they're just like oh my mood
changed and you're like yeah but you
started a sushi restaurant so there's
there's the practicality of staying
focused maybe launching another
restaurant because here in Vegas there's
people who like they've launched a
really cool Fusion spot now they want to
launch some place else great but what's
the focus and if you really want to
build a big brand I think that's the
thing and even just a successful brand
you want to be known for something you
want to be known for one thing and it
may kind of be a mood it may be New York
it may be modern kind of a hip-hop
culture perspective which could cover a
lot of variety within it it may be like
entrepreneurship Tim Ferriss kind of
biohacking which again you may talk
about investing you may talk about
biohacking but like there's a focus
there there's a particular thing that's
there if it's random uh if your YouTube
channel is random over the Long Haul
you're going to get random results and
you probably won't have long-term
traction and you certainly won't build a
legacy
[Music]
this video is brought to you by stream
yard stream yard is our go-to platform
for streaming to YouTube and Facebook
with an incredibly easy to use interface
for built-in branding transitions text
lower thirds and seamlessly bringing on
guests it really is one of the best
options when it comes to live streaming
and what's so cool is they've
implemented a brand new feature called
local recording take control of your
audio and video with local recordings by
separating out your audio and video from
your guests this feature gives you the
control over your content for later use
making it perfect for podcasts and video
creators just go to streamwoodthink.com
to get started now
to just carry on with that restaurant
analogy I really like that because one
of the things that I am often telling
people is to think about why is someone
watching your content and it takes a lot
of self-awareness because just the you
know you go to you know a taco shop
right and maybe the person of the
YouTube channel here is the restaurant
owner the cook right so and they're like
well they're coming to my restaurant
because they just want a good experience
with food and so then they bring out
cheeseburgers and they're all confused
it's like well that's not actually why
they're coming here they're actually
coming here because they love your tacos
and so it's like is someone coming to
your channel because you make funny
videos maybe but they actually might be
coming to your channel because of your
funny videos on sports or something so
it's like being self-aware and like and
experiment right and then you can see
that video you know didn't resonate with
audience and so maybe sometimes it's a
new channel maybe it's like let's stick
in this Lane and that can really help
people I think just go further faster
and the the next statement here is if
you don't get traction after 30 videos
you should pivot your niche this is
advice that I've heard
um but generally I know there's a lot of
deep diving you need is this true or
false like at what point should the
person
pivot I think
maybe the word isn't pivot I think the
word would be Packaging
I think because if you're posting 30
videos good job like clap it up like
that's that's a lot of work but four
views but four views you might be
packaging the information incorrectly or
not to its most Effectiveness uh you
might not be titling and thumbnail
storytelling uh to its best ability but
that's what I would say I would say
think about the package of the videos
because if you're just beating a dead
horse with your 30 uploads and you're
just throwing it up and you're not case
sensitive like on the titles you don't
care like yeah I uploaded 30 videos but
like how how is it that is so smart and
it reminds me of your pbd conversation
you were telling us and how the locker
room can you explain that because part
of that is if you if you're posting 30
videos and you aren't getting views what
you're saying is like
you don't need to Pivot your channel
because you might pivot to a channel and
still fail so the packaging and I I like
that you said packaging because title
and thumbnail and then even your video
those are like main things to focus on
but that comes with going to the locker
room yeah I mean going in the locker
room people think that experience is the
best teacher and it's not you have the
experience of posting 30 videos but
experience isn't the best teacher
evaluated experience is the best teacher
that means actually going back and
thinking about what are the takeaways
what all what can I learn from this
which I would encourage people number
one if you are self-aware
that can be something you do yourself if
you can start studying YouTube analytics
that'll give you some insights but you
probably need an outside perspective
because a lot of us we need we need
coaching we need help we just need
somebody that can see what we can't see
sometimes it's hard to see the forest
from the trees and so I would also say
that I think it's probably false that
you need to Pivot your Niche at 30
videos and I would agree with Omar that
there's probably just something else you
should pivot first
and one of those that I think is the
biggest missed opportunity is pivoting
your video formats
and so you've done 30 videos they're
talking head with no editing and then
they're like it's not working well what
if you still are talking about personal
finance but now you're doing a voiceover
and it's all b-roll and there's captions
on screen that would be a faceless
version of similar content not talking
head what if you figured out how to do
the Whiteboard drawn videos and you
presented the same information you're
doing book summaries it's a booktube
thing it's huge people want to watch a
summary of a book but you just sitting
there talking they they want a different
format and that could be you write a
better script there's some b-roll there
or there's you know the Whiteboard
videos there's software that'll do that
for you and you tweak that software
maybe it's a video podcast format that
is a little bit different than what you
were previously doing there's different
variables and levers you should try
because your experimenting hasn't
stopped but maybe if there's no results
after 30 videos definitely should pivot
something and just understanding the
variety of the things you can pivot to
keep the experiments going but change
some of the variables I love it I love
it I think that's so good to hear for
someone you know in that situation so
I'm glad we touched on that because I
know that is like a lonely tough spot to
be in where it's not working and you're
just not sure what to do and we actually
did a free YouTube challenge and so
we'll we'll put a link in the
description if you guys want to join the
next one but uh someone in the challenge
they were in our VIP group and they were
wondering if they were Shadow banned and
so this statement
um stemmed from from this person I have
thousands of subscribers and it was
mainly from shorts we'll get to that
next but thousands of Subs barely any
views is YouTube Shadow Banning my
content is this true or false does
YouTube do this
um I know it depends on on but like what
do you guys think
I I could start I think it's I think
it's false I think it's false but I
think the extreme is true yeah I do
think sometimes YouTube Just chooses a
Creator yeah and just gases their
content well I do I've seen that but why
do you think is that happening I don't
and that's where like I call it the
Unicorn effect like you kind of can't
put your finger on it quite necessarily
like I was talking about a comedian uh a
new comedian a young Mexican dude that's
just been showing up like crazy on my TV
YouTube shorts on my you know and I've
been watching my Instagram I don't know
I'm like the algorithm on the internet
feel like I caught this guy you know
he's only got a couple stand-ups and but
at the same time he's not like trying to
like break he's just being him doing his
thing and it just the time and then boom
it you know but I don't think YouTube is
like
and I know there might even be some
people in our community that are
offended by that because they'd say of
course they Shadow ban well here's what
I mean number one is I think that 99 of
people who say they're being Shadow
banned are just putting out crappy
content and they're trying to blame
somebody else and it's a victim
perspective and you're gonna lose with
that mentality
is it true that
YouTube and Google is more of a liberal
leaning organization yes and is it true
that at times they have been harder it
would seem on sometimes conservative
voices yes however there's plenty of
conservative channels that are going
viral getting a lot of views and the
reason I say false is to empower The
Listener to say that the only mentality
that will lead you to a winning YouTube
channel is just assuming that shadow
Banning is not happening and if you're
not getting views work harder if you're
not getting views be more creative if
you're not getting views hit it from a
different angle if you're not getting
views on certain topics we'll find the
topics you can talk about and move your
audience somewhere else so what do a lot
of conservative channels do they are
also building up their following on
rumble or they're building their own Ott
wait hold on what is Rumble uh am I I
don't know what this is Rumble is a
video sharing platform kind of favoring
conservative voices because they're not
gonna uh be as and anybody can post
there but a lot of people diversify
Their audience over there or
um it's a play I mean Andrew Tate went
over to rumble and I don't think people
would necessarily maybe you consider him
conservative probably not but I mean
just speaking against Big Brand big Tech
or or the Matrix as he calls it and all
this different stuff punchline is again
I think you have to be Savvy you have to
be shrewd but but 99 of people that
think they're getting Shadow banned I
would say YouTube doesn't even know you
exist actually you're not getting Shadow
banned you just need to improve your
content and and because what are you
going to do about it as well I mean that
that's my thought is like it's a
disempowering place because the only
real option you have is to complain
about it what are you going to email
Google they're not gonna do anything you
know like and so there's plenty of
people from all different beliefs and
backgrounds who find a way they they put
publish certain content on YouTube they
build up an email list again they build
up their own paid subscription site they
just find a different way to communicate
and maybe they put out certain types of
content you know my friend Ruslan he
will talk about he is thoughtful about
certain things he talks about on YouTube
and then he's like and we we have like
unedited stuff in our patreon so it
YouTube is still the play YouTube is the
number one video platform some people
may want to diversify but I would never
leave YouTube he just may be thoughtful
about your approach but I think the
shadow Banning thing just gets over
hyped and I think you can find you also
you can get what's called a confirmation
bias you hear a couple stories and
you're like see that this Creator this
happened you're like yeah but there's
also these creators over here that have
the exact same viewpoints that are
pulling 50 million views a month so it's
like
you can what you want to see is kind of
what you will see I'd say put your head
down do the work
be wise as serpents and harmless as
doves and who cares about Shadow Banning
man get to work get to work I love that
and I would just add too that you might
have a lot of subscribers that doesn't
mean you're gonna get a lot of views and
so just know that this subscribe that's
on YouTube the new dirty data it is kind
of it can be definitely it can be and so
people get you know confused like I'm
Shadow banned but it's like you might
have done really well in the past maybe
you had some shorts blow up you got a
couple thousand Subs now but your videos
like you said aren't doing that well the
one other thing I'd add to that is where
I think people need to be careful to
actually not get Shadow banned is
understanding that YouTube is a company
that they run ads so people post like
crazy content I think there's just a lot
of kind of stuff with the milk boys
going on and and they were getting I
think kicked off of YouTube and their
content all this kind of stuff and so
because they're posting you know more
content that is not as Advertiser
friendly and so keep that in mind like
and is arguably crime in certain
situations like I mean whether illegal
and and I you know like that's the kind
of stuff you get into because of course
during lockdowns they're doing huge
meetups they're they're putting
observably potentially like the public
in danger and you could debate all that
but when you step into that territory
it's just a great conversation because
what some people one thing that gets
people really mad is right now YouTube's
cracking down on swearing and that if
you really swear at all that you're no
longer going to be considered family
friendly and they're so offended you're
like yeah well then either swear because
you want to and figure out how to
monetize elsewhere or don't do it like
people just get so butt hurt all the
time yeah they really did like it's like
dude it's a free platform that if you
kind of they get to make the rules right
and so it could be you know swearing it
could be doing dangerous things or
dangerous pranks and then it could be uh
well did you see all the new updates
with Gamers and so even within the first
like 10 seconds there's certain
advertisers are just you're not gonna be
able to be monetized uh if basically if
you show violence within the first 10
seconds or if you or if there's like
blood in the video game like there's
there's new rules coming out for certain
niches and people need to play by the
rules of YouTube if they're giving you
your paycheck that's right and gamers
are like I can't believe it I can't even
play any games based on this it's not
even like ma17 it's like ma13 on the
violence and you're like okay man okay I
understand but like if you are a true
Entertainer and you build up a true
audience like you can do Channel
memberships you could do patreon you can
uh diversify your audience on different
platforms you can figure it out I'm
empathetic because I mean depending on
what you're doing people just I mean
it's like you want to have your cake and
eat it too and in some cases it seems
like that doesn't necessarily work but
there are going to be those who make
excuses and complain and play the victim
card and there are going to be those who
find a way and get results and I think
that the winning strategy is the
strategy of finding a way and figuring
it out to be yourself to be authentic
but to not complain about YouTube
cracking down on you it is what it is
man you got to just play with take
ownership and uh play the hand you're
dealt yeah yeah so I got two quick fire
round quests or statements and then I
want to finish on a on a good one that I
think the listeners are gonna to love to
hear your guys's thoughts on this so
fire around Omar the video packaging
matters more than the video itself let
me reword it the thumbnail and title
matter more than the video itself is
that true or false it's false it's false
because
as soon as they click on it
then it's then I click off of it and
then YouTube's like they're clicking on
it and then they're clicking off of it
we're not going to show this to more
people yes that's so something I was
thinking about with this question too is
there was this study we'll show it if
you're watching uh the YouTube version
of this but he did this uh study where
he used to work at Google and now he's
like building some cool software uh for
like YouTube extension plugins and stuff
basically he found through like 60
000 different uh videos that he ran
through his software that the number one
predictor of views was average view
duration times click-through rate so
ultimately what that means is it is both
but what you're saying makes so much
sense because if your click-through rate
is super high
but then your average view duration gets
crushed it doesn't matter so yeah I love
that answer but what would you say true
or false on that one that would say
false as well yeah yeah like the the
video has to be good however and goodbye
information yeah delivering on like this
that real estate if you like this real
estate agent in Las Vegas is just
booming right now and his thumbnails are
like they're simple kind of random but
they're simple like burning house behind
him
he's doing Loom video just looking at
articles and uploading his loom video
but the information it's the potency of
the content you know it delivers and so
yeah uh we actually we actually posted a
video on think media I don't know if
Sean knows this so um we might get in
trouble here a little bit but we posted
a video on think media accidentally
without a thumbnail and it performed one
out of it today and Kyle do you remember
how long it was without them I caught it
like three hours after three hours so
and it was one out of ten one there's
some branding there people Nothing media
and so they clicked on it and then like
they were just hooked in and so
um it just it's kind of funny there is
there's the point exactly okay uh one
last fire round you uh to be a YouTuber
you need to be an extrovert totally
totally false yeah what's interesting
actually you know we've all now
connected we've we go to vid Summit and
different events and growth video live
and we've connected with so many
creators and one of the themes you'll
see is first of all successful YouTube
creators are all different ages all
different personalities all different
backgrounds
but a large majority of successful
YouTube creators are introverts because
the wiring of an introvert is to what
you're doing is you're sitting in a
bedroom a home office alone talking to a
camera not even a person and staring at
a Glass lens to make eye contact it's a
pretty introverted situation extroverts
are thriving off of sitting across from
someone at coffee and what we're trying
to do is imagine that happening because
you're literally there by yourself so
that's kind of the introvert Advantage
but I would say that almost nobody has
really an advantage it's just about
learning the skills punching fear in the
face because literally every personality
type has figured out how to succeed on
YouTube yeah and you mentioned earlier
about like
Focus
I I might get Flack for this but like
you know people who are like on the
Spectrum and not in a bad way on the
Spectrum as in they have an insane level
of focus are usually the YouTubers that
are just like so you meet them in person
they're just they're kind of just
socially awkward but like they're
incredible creators because of just how
they're wired
um and I've just I don't know even like
entrepreneurs who have grasped the whole
creating
um you know Journey they're like awkward
I don't know I like I mean like we're
involved in church and stuff I like I
want to make sure I don't stay awkward
or get awkward but this can get you
awkward yeah over time I mean yeah
you're thinking about a lot you're
cooking up a lot of things and focus is
a superpower because if you have to get
away from your desk and like unwind
that's totally fine but the person who
could be head down disciplined
methodically going through the things
connecting Divergent ideas and
strategies yeah like you'd be talking to
people at a video conference and and
they're they're still calculating
algorithms you know thinking about their
next project or something yeah it's a
whole different kind of breed yeah uh I
love it no there's great answers
um now this statement is that you need
to post consistently to grow on YouTube
even if that means just once a month so
the priority here is like do you really
need to be
consistent with the Tuesday with the
first first weekend of the month
um yeah today you know maybe this has
changed over time but today is that true
it is true
and I think consistency is misunderstood
so it's true because
I think the idea of Tuesday morning at 8
A.M and that kind of thing is is fine
and that can build like momentum I think
what consistency does though is
consistency if you're going to do
anything in life that's going to be
truly successful you need to be
consistent at it it wasn't like I just
invested in my marriage one year and
then it was successful for the rest of
life you have to keep investing in it
that would be the dream though
if there was only a way we wrote a book
The the one-year marriage investment for
Lifelong Love
uh Lincoln bio so uh I mean so when you
think about it it's like it's it's
consistently showing up for your
audience it's consistently delivering
value if you were if you're building a
bigger brand because creators are doing
things nobody has to do this but you can
do things like meetups or you could do
things like events or you'd launch
podcasts you launch other stuff like
people want more they want to connect
with you so the day of the week is part
of it and there's certainly I mean Mr
Beast is at like every three weeks or
something are his uploads so there's
that those and those are also becoming I
heard one person extrapolated out
they're actually becoming like mid-tier
film level because of the amount of
editing and time two three million goes
into each one or two to four million
goes in each one compared to the amount
of time if you extrapolated that out it
like equates to 10 to 20 million which
is like the price of uh certain mid-tier
movies that are crushing so he's really
playing a whole different deal so it
depends on the model but when I do what
Mr Beast is doing his consistency though
he's also got a gaming channel so even
his connection level like he's got a
reaction thing going on but he's also he
also is doing things he's doing meetups
so it's like consistency is just you
consistently showing up for people you
care about you consistently showing up
whether that's maybe on other social
media different people writing
newsletters so consistency I know you're
you're narrowing it to the YouTube and
and because the way the algorithm works
and if you also rank videos
you're consistent even when you're not
consistent because you actually are
still showing up for people but they
want more from you it's you think about
an artist it lets down your fans if
there's demand for a new album you don't
bring them new music
so consistency would be to keep showing
up and keep creating and keep innovating
I think that's not just about like a
profitable life I think that's about a
fulfilled and effective life that's also
about loving and serving people
and and giving more and continuing to
serve over time which also would
indicate you should you should also take
a break you should take us a battle call
you should take some time off but it's
much more about the long game of
continuing to show up with a consistent
message consistent brand consistent
value consistent creativity New
Opportunities we're thinking about doing
a a a celebration on the think media
podcast and having people come out to
Vegas and come to a theater and meet us
in person and maybe you know do do a
live share we're just announcing this
live I mean I'm just brainstorming it
around the podcast right now but I mean
part of it let us know in the comments
if you wanna if that should be a thing I
think it'd be cool yeah actually that
would that would be RSVP uh and we'll
see if but but part of that is also we
know it actually would be harder than
what we're doing right now it'd be
Logistics and whatnot like the think
media team I'd have like a side like oh
that's that's gonna be but but but why
because of this community because of of
trying to think about touch points and
doing things and memorable moments and
all those types of things that go deeper
and if you don't show up consistently
then you're not going to create those
moments and you're ultimately not going
to create a movement because consistency
yields dependency
and people want to depend on you and if
you're not showing up they can't and I
even think about phases I consume people
in phases like I have a season I consume
this Creator and then I'm over it
they're still going though and they're
still meeting new people then I find a
new thing and that's probably you know
if you're listening to this or watching
this you're you're gonna you're gonna
find us for a season and when you're
done thank you so much for being with us
for a season we're gonna keep going and
we're going to keep posting valuable
content because there's more people to
meet and or when you want to come back
we'll be here you know there's just
something about being Dependable as a
creator dependable
oh uh that's it for the podcast episode
click on the screen watch another one I
think you're gonna love this episode I
don't even know what it is but click
click on it watch it